guys watch this oh come on jump jump do
it yeah I think somebody would Jeff this
is so sad why did they keep jumping so
what does it stop I also have a paper
form now very epic so now I can just
make a lot the rocket of course means we
can fly around in the nether because
today we're gonna find the last biome
and today mark my words
we're gonna find nether right apparently
I found it in the last episode and
didn't pick it up that's right the
rarest metal in the game
that's just how rich I am gamers that's
just how rich I am isn't that right
chicken why did you not make a sound
it's so understood that's so disturbing
squeal yeah that's right that's better
alright so another glorious day in
Minecraft on 20fps hold up alright there
you go that's a little better
good morning spend how are you damn a
little dance for me girl yeah
alright let's check why do I not hear
silence why don't wanna hear some sounds
this is supposed to make a sound what
happened here what happened to your rap
oh it broke how can you hear it but let
me I think I've got death sounds back
okay it's back I can hear you son shut
up shut up no one's talking to you no
one you will be nothing that's what I
thought what happened here alright the
door is the gate is open so you have a
bet more responsibility shut up shut up
oh my god I wish it ah it was better
without sound well every time you have a
big responsibility okay no one can leave
the gates are open so then you tell me
I'm gonna say hi to your cursed son
Alabama we pray for you Alabama we pray
for a what in them get out of night we
pray to you Alabama Lord of the nether
round to have a safe journey across safe
lands please bless us Alabama Alabama
saying what the hell are those ty what
this this kill it if it walks on lava it
has to die I think I'm pretty sure those
are the rules
oh god I want to can you can you get out
of the way fine
what the hell what are these stop living
yeah yeah
Oh why are they there's so many new
stuff I have no idea what it even is
hold up I got to sit closer to the
screen I can't see anything
all right mission to find the new place
let's go oh god this is so scary I don't
I don't like yeah I don't like this
it making me very nervous I think one of
them was sort of this way hi guys
okay all right we're just keep playing
it feels like I shouldn't be doing this
but it's the quickest way and I really
don't know how else you would do it
really Oh God all right what do we got
here I can fly through here yeah that's
what I'm talking about you got kneed me
big balls big balls in big brain all
right let's keep going oh god it said
let's not go there
we're making move son we're making moves
because I'm in their groove oh okay we
found one of them I don't know
Oh God we're gonna we have to light
perfect climbing really good up there
oh that's pretty smooth hey buddy how
you then I'll trade you Nuggets alright
they're delicious they taste good
they're nutritious that just give me the
other right
alright you understand you don't nuggets
this guy doesn't like Nuggets I only
have nuggets
I forgot my gold where's my gold dude
where's my gold I swear I had a lot of
gold dude I swear I'm rich I swear it
listen to me
listen to me I swear I have money listen
I'm good for it I'm good for the money
and I got dead eyes nuggets over there
then you mean nothing to me do you mean
nothing to me yeah yeah yeah I said it
okay so apparently you can dig down now
yeah yeah you can dig down in Minecraft
shut up I wasn't done in my sentence you
can dig down and I think I took a
screenshot let me see
okay why 13 and why 12 you can find
ancient deborah's that's what we're
going to find gamers ancient the brass
capably there are three new biomes like
oh my god I all nearly dead then I
nearly that dead alright lets swoop down
here I'll broke my face gold gold is
good right Nuggets biscuit nugget in a
biscuit nugget biscuit black potatoes
that's that's lyrics all right I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die hey guys
ow I broke my face I broke it
is there any wooden then there is wood
in the nether of course I'm so stupid I
could have made I could have melted ah
my brain so small I can't help it
alright don't worry that means oh Jesus
missus what happened here what
oh hey Oh nuggets nuggets yeah those are
mushrooms okay all right let's make sure
we're not killing our life threads well
plus we have to make it back as well oh
god oh god all right all right all right
all right fine fine fine
this will do this will do do I not have
a connects did
if Sven was here he would do something
useful that's all I'm gonna say about
that
it does sound like strangling of a toad
stop my owl stop judging me everyone was
like why do you know what that sounds
like
are you serious you got to be kidding me
dude all right can I make a workbench
out of this please say yes that was this
yes what the hell how did I even make
that I'm so dumb okay so now what we can
make nuggets oh yeah oh yeah I told him
I was good for it
dude I have so many never realized yeah
yeah rich 14 yeah yeah let's make some
bargains now one thing I want the nether
right Armour eibon's all right the
children stay away from me I don't waste
gold on kids hey hey listen kid take it
yours now gimme good give me good come
on what Iren did I give you gold you
dumbass I can just right-click on them
splash up fine
No all right fine you give me something
now neither right never the right come
on come on come on come on come on come
on come up recipient really do I look
like some guy that just walks around
caring hey stop giving me obsidian oh
look it's a child I would never hurt
that child so dead you're so dead yeah
run run little piggy little bit can I
write them maybe I should take one with
me home
yeah yeah take the babies wait I can't
put a leash on them when then sure
usually you're gonna die then you can
keep running keep running it's pathetic
I love it
keep running that's pathetic you get one
too everyone gets one I'm Oprah I'm
Oprah no stop this what did the other
guy drop Oh what no no it what 14
are you sure buddy are you sure dude
this guy's Rachel just keep talking to
you hey hey you're my best friend
remember okay so goal that's the way to
their hearts huh understand really
strings do I look like a guy that needs
strings and 21 that's pretty generous
shut up learn English download duolingo
now you dumb okay this guy's guy got a
hat let's talk to you
hey come on me come on man give me good
give me good
get the child away from me I don't want
that get me good stop get the children
away from me I'm not afraid for them I'm
afraid what I will do to them what is
this is garbage
you're garbage to trash all right fine
switch you what will you do for this
what can you go offer me you know it's
written all right and they're pros are
pretty good what do I throw away Agatha
a raw chicken I got a lot of us the
child just take damage that's awesome
all right we got three more chances you
give me these magma cream sounds kind of
yes this is a proper minecraft cringe
reaction okay so now I think you put the
nether brick like this eh-oh eh-oh eh-oh
eh-oh what what do I do with the nether
breaks I have to smelt them in the
furnace okay well then we should go home
I heal my Electra maybe I should just
kill them all
yes yes yes you will pay all right all
right let's do this
listen listen listen I got what I came
for
I got what I came for I need to heal my
light right from my fault I'll spare the
children all right if you feel bad I'll
spread the children but the rest of them
will be let's just pick a good spot and
I will snipe them snipe them out all of
them yeah all right I wish I had TNT
that we can I make tea now guys this is
PewDiePie here do you copy
I got locked on target ready to fire at
any issue yeah what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do you're pathetic
[Music]
you can't hurt what is already hurt
inside yeah heal my Electra my queen
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't run little child don't run I just
need your life points I just want your
life give me your life
well you trying to fight back that's
cute your Pig and pig going going going
yeah
Shh look the pigs are on my sign now
Doug he's like yeah dude that was
awesome
cheers mate he brought me a peace
offering that's so cute
look we're cool all right we're not cool
but you know what
I killed the mom I killed the mom and
the baby goes BAE all right I kind of
don't want I kind of don't want to
actually buy that I kind of like don't
want to die in this game all right
we're shooting me all right my electrons
gonna huff a lot yes yes more power yes
yes Oh God not not the boar what a shame
hey I got cooked potatoes let's get rid
of the raw chicken oh no I don't like
eating chicken wha look at him it's Jojo
weak [ __ ]
sorry I shouldn't swear is that all of
them wiped them out all of them
oh I hear I hear more squealing hey
little piggy don't be afraid don't be
afraid I wonder what they drop is it
worth investigating I don't see them
really spawning anywhere let's go home
gamers let's make the nether right
Armour poor can i okay Wow 40s wings
I like angel that's what the pygmies are
saying in their own language that's
right I started their language duolingo
it's whatever
we're fine I wasn't even afraid oh great
Alabama
I kneel to thy thy lordship thank you
for blessing this I will pay no Alabama
I'm so sorry Jesus
eat sorry sorry about that one that's a
bit awkward you look like you're stuck
in that no sit on your chair Alabama
it's not safe trust me trust me trust me
trust me trust me trust me your core
chip please all right you stay there now
when I return
Alabama's doing great don't worry I'm
treating him so good we're like best
friends and in here everything is good
lovely that fetus meetup that's what I
thought that's what I thought yeah today
was a good day we got good
today's rations will be increased by a
total of five percent that's right
you're welcome I'm a good leader I take
care of my people what did you hear that
what are the odds
okay so so I need I need a bus what what
all right I need a blast furnace I don't
think this will do it's a pretty good
loot today I will say yeah okay it's a
blast furnace
I forgot how you a blast furnace okay so
apparently we need smooth stone for
whatever reason and we need a furnace
and some iron I never done this I
thought I did everything in Minecraft I
thought I'd beat the game right gamers
why can't I make one do I smooth stone
oh it's not smooth stone how do I get it
smooth eh I gotta burn it again maybe
I'm so easily amazed I bill like these
awesome redstone contraptions look no
one's ever done that but then I see
smooth stone and I go one two three four
twenty ten to eight what is your
favorite book in Minecraft blast furnace
that's badass let's put you right here
yeah that's where I wanted it so the guy
that I watch use lava to melt I don't
know if I need lava
it just sounds
what the hell what at what I'm never
nether bricks are useless
are you kidding oh they're useless guys
hey why didn't you goddamn it what what
am I looking for then nether right ingot
which spawns from nether right scrap
which spawns from ancient debriefs
urine that the right scrap you're right
you're all right fine you know what
we're gonna do
I got you fam don't talk to me deep
that's right
Alabama we're gonna make a mind listen
to this we're gonna make a mine ensign
out of the mine how cool how cool is
that
yeah all right let's go Sven spends
cursed son out of Alabama and PewDiePie
adventures isn't that exciting okay so
the hell are you doing you're all right
where should we put the mine I think
here's a good spot I like this so they
spawn at lava level which is a little
scary I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
scared but it's okay as long as you're
not scared nothing can hurt you yes yes
yes luckily these are very quick so y12
where are we on 4500 my god we gotta go
so deep dude shoulda brought deep am i
right am i right
am i right Alabama he didn't like that
one he didn't like that one that's fine
it's a sensitive topic in this family I
get it all right so how in Lord's name
am I going to do this then how in sweet
Lord baby Alabama Jesus am I going to do
that I can't do that
hey careful Alabama Slama been laminae
Oh
boom about him all right we're gonna
have to find somewhere else to dig
perhaps in here follow me child and be
careful it's ticket day coochie-coochie
and now we dig straight down to smell
yeah
dude I love it Alabama I need to build
it back all right let's make sure we
don't think too fast though right yeah
yeah I see all right where are we 37
dude these are they're deep dude all
right deep get it all right so don't
touch those because he will die and I
don't want you to die it will look bad
on my track record I got a reputation to
protect
no one dies on my watch no Alabama stop
it stop it now you can stop it now the
BAM oh that's lava that's lava Alabama
not love but Alabama stop it all right
we stopped it the Bama Alabama I love
them Alabama you like that you like that
song Alabama
if only you had a theme song or
something like that with your name in it
that'd be so cool about maybe like a
theme song about the feeling of home and
security and family and all that stuff
that'd be cool
if you I don't know I just can't think
of any I feel like you're judging me
stop doing that were you afraid he's
afraid of jump isn't he coward listen
listen this is unexplored territory for
all of us Alabama
oh you're sitting that's we okay all
right be careful though Alabama I'm
serious the issue here is not too big
fast the issue is the lava the
inevitable lava that will come
all right you hit the lava will make a
turn how about that Jesus Christ maybe
we should just scour out this entire
area like this
oh yeah we're gonna find it we're gonna
find it this is how you murder your
diamond pickaxe by the way god dammit I
can't see anything
I hate these lights it's too dark oh my
god my pickaxe is dead alright I guess
we head back all right looks like we're
gonna have to kill some people so I can
heal my pickaxe I'm sorry it's for the
greater good of mankind okay here we go
nice let's just let's just keep it cool
others and others Enderman they're kind
of hard to kill I just need your XP it's
better to kill the Pigman they were like
rich and stuff and the man you're not
really good for anything alright this
isn't work I need to find the pigment if
I can find the pigment we should be all
set what whoa whoa no oh God I made a
big mistake oh stop it you're scaring me
dude there's blue flames you see this
stop it Swedish Swedish remember
remember never forget e what are those
look at that what is there
we found it gamers oh this is new solar
soil that's me after I take a big poop
boy am i right gamers yeah dad you're
dead you're dead nothing personal kid
let's use the ender pearls why not I'm
here now so what's the dealy over this
place dude what do I find in this area
all the other ones were so distinct look
at this dude wait a minute
sorry let's fly over here 360 oh that
was snakes the mast oh I'm sorry did
that kill your little friend I'm so
sorry about that
you're terrible I swear so what is this
what are the house
very ominous this place indeed yes let's
mine it with my fast just wait
basalt bath salts finally they put it in
Minecraft
apparently Bessel is a real thing it's
Aeneas rock extrusive mafic extrusive
igneous rock form from the rapid cooling
of magnesium rich in the iron-rich lava
okay oh it's basically like lava rock
yeah but what is it doing minecraft I
don't care by real life cringe you can
make a basalt generator that's so cool
so it's basically like a new form of
stone block and they form because lava
fall cools in this area I guess it's
cooler that's why the the fire has a
dissing different to English it has a
different color okay guys I can't do
this guess you can feel like forms and
stuff here what are those you know yeah
stop leave me alone he's a frame he's a
frame look at him
alright we're doing it Jesus alright
watch it a kitty cat oh god there's so
many other okay I'm good with
that's I was done dude there's so many
died thank you stop stop so you can make
blue flames with these that's kind of
cool so what are these
looks like monuments how did he die from
that
this is quartz sir sounds like bones
bone block block
what I like the sound they make that's
why they're skeletons in here because
get it because yeah oh yeah oh god they
spawn like crazy in here this is a
dangerous area boys but I am Not Afraid
yeah yeah they just keep spawning in
here that means you can farm them in
here you know people are coming up with
ways to break the game already so we got
bones stuff we got cobblestone at the
bottom we got a castle in it that's so
cool and so what a difference to the
nether all right guys I'm being
impressed right now
don't make me regret it I was just about
to really leave a good year yelp review
what a crazy area Oh Mike there's so
many of them are you serious hey boys
this is the privilege of the hoe the
short boy no no illegal illegal no God
hey god damn it what how oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god eat
keep the chicken this is bad this is red
okay we're fine Oh with their skeleton
yeah thanks buddy
definite it's gonna be easier to farm
the wither now right what just happened
what how so lucky all right we're back
home gamers Jesus Christ and I realize
how dark it is Alabama I got some
sacrifices for you I know you like bones
so I got you some bone blocks for your
house don't you just love it look at him
he's so happy you live hearing that with
your soil and you can have some chicken
because I love you even though you're
horrible and shouldn't exist that's
right hey to to wither skulls I think I
have enough to some of the wither I'm
back Flynn that wood thumb we didn't get
the nether right it's okay it's okay
shut up here again I brought you a gift
as well I know how much you like Gucci
pants so I got you these are specially
imported there you go I know he loves
some deep I got you and a gas here
because I know you like people crying so
there you going and because you're a
crying little boy that's right I should
probably repair the meatball I'll do
that for next time there's a lot of
stuff I want to do actually I don't know
if you remember we made the inside clean
but we haven't cleaned that we're having
cleaned the top of it I've always wanted
to do that oh yeah thank you for
watching another episode of Minecraft if
you enjoyed smash like subscribe for
more videos I appreciate it I upload
every single day and see you tomorrow
hey dope oh and remember check out the
March that we're doing right now it's
support the ocean foundation it's very
nice it has shrimp on it
that's it you know what's big peepee
ooh they play PewDiePie's pixel ings of
course pixel ins is a creature
collecting game I'm the primary
shareholder over a bazillion players
have downloaded and it's got a perfect
score it's safe to say it's the most
popular game of all time PewDiePie pick
slings is awesome deal with it deal with
it
[Music]